oui
et le commerce
comment ça va
il s'adapte
dans nos campagnes
partout elles se sont implantées les
supérettes sont devenus les rênes des
bourgs alors qu'ici à barenton le passé
saute aux yeux
tout ce qui avait pignon sur rue tenez
commerce 87 artisans et enseigne aux
diverses dans les années 50 et pas moins
de quatorze bistrot
un sondage express au barenton le
joliment nommée café du coin nous le
confirme bien la preuve
chiffres à l'appui l'ancien chef lieu de
canton du sud manche
la petite capitale de la pomme à cidre
souffre elle aussi mais pas question de
se laisser aller au catastrophisme
illustrations en couleurs avec cette
jeune fleuriste
soucieuse de vivre et travailler au pays
j'ai créé il ya bientôt trois ans et je
compte bien rester ici encore encore
plusieurs années puisqu'il ya de
l'allemand voilà de la demande
il y en a aussi au relais du parc le
restaurant de la place les hamelin ils
sont à l'oeuvre depuis plus de trente
ans il se verrait bien souffler un peu
la clientèle est toujours là il n'y a
pas de souci mais on voudrait bien remis
un jeune qui serait motivée et puis même
s'il faut l'aider au départ mais
personne
quatre ans que ça dure la mairie juste
en face est au courant mais elle ne se
mêle pas de commerce
peut-être qu'il doit tirer vers le bas
les tarifs les prix qu'ils demandent
pour avoir dont un successeur parce que
c'est ça le problème
ça me paraît pas excessif je crois que
les murs le fond je passe au jeu de 150
alors je crois qu'on va le bâtiment je
pense pas que ce soit il les convainc
pas lyon ça vaut ça ça valait ça
accroché à l'étude notariale montre à
quel point le foncier bâti à dégringoler
dans le secteur il ya sûrement des
affaires à saisir pour qui veut y croire
chez les voisins de saint georges de
rouelley la municipalité a choisi
d'autres voies
un petit coup d'oeil à la démographie
locale montre que ça se maintient plutôt
depuis le début du siècle ici monsieur
le maire a choisi de casser sa tirelire
pour relancer le commerce spécialité la
location vente
et voilà qui est devenu un garage qui
est évident aujourd'hui c'est une grosse
entreprise et là je crois que j'ai
quatre ou cinq ans prié la station 24/24
et depuis il a racheté une carrosserie à
domfront et comme il n'ya pas de boer
attractif sans sa supérette saint
georges a aussi construit ce qu'il
fallait
une affaire qui tourne ça fait neuf ans
que je suis installé donc je voudrais
pouvoir acheter pour diminuer les coûts
de loyer aussi est il qu'à l'avenir
c'est sur un local qui m'appartiennent
on est donc ici au pays du maire
aménageurs du territoire que revoilà
avec sa voisine de saint cyr du bailleul
ils font cause commune sur l'équipement
scolaire et se sont particulièrement
bien débrouillé dans leurs derniers
programmes de grands travaux de 144 400
440 euros de subventions tout ça pour la
quarantaine d'élèves des deux communes
on espère avec des écoles attractive
on peut peut-être augmenter chose de
positif
ironie du sort au même moment à deux pas
de là les forces encore vives de saint
georges et de sa banlieue se disputaient
autour d'un concours de belote dans une
salle à peine assez vaste pour cette
vénérable assemblée
[Musique]
non